the idea is like having the
continuation of the sky as if it were
as if it were a curtain or that it gets
opposite then when one is and what
we did precisely here in this
space because there is a street that
continue that is whether it starts in Mexico and
continued in the USA but there is this border
this barrier that prevents movement to
through this street then creating
with what the feeling as if one more
was the sky
why not see this space as if
we were a humanity we are not two
cultures say yes we are different
cultures but that under the same sky there
then like that one unit and bring
bring or create that sense of union